No experience, no resume,...
...no problem at all in some of Europe's top tourist destinations.
Hotels, bars and restaurants in Spain and Portugal...
...are fighting a fierce war for staff.
Waiters and other workers are in such short supply...
...that firms are willing to hire almost anyone willing to join.
There shouldn't be a shortage of job seekers,...
...with youth unemployment above 20% in Portugal and near 30% in Spain.
But workers and unions blame unsociable hours,...
...low pay and short contracts for putting people off the hospitality sector.
That leaves Spain's catering trade alone short of 200,000 workers.
It's a similar story over in Portugal, where hotels need another 15,000 staff.
The shortages come at a bad time,...
...with demand rebounding after years of lockdowns.
Searches for summer flights to Spain and Portugal have jumped...
...as much as 156 percent from last year.
Travel looks set to match or surpass pre-health crisis levels.
The tourists want to come to Spain and Portugal,...
...but bars and hotels may not be ready to welcome them.